hello everybody
hi my name is Masha
um some of you may have met me already
as part of office hours and seen me post
on Ed and things like that I'm really
excited to be giving the lectures today
it's going to be in a slightly different
format than tenu's or Chris's so feel
free to give me feedback on that
afterwards on Ed or by email whatever
you like but the topic today is actually
kind of fun
um so we're going to start our foray a
little bit into deep learning so neural
networks
um
I'm assuming everyone here has heard of
neural networks before
anyone who hasn't
yeah that's what I thought pretty much
so it'll be fun to see how the ideas of
what's happening in the state of the art
actually come back to all the things
we've been talking about so far so ideas
and linear regression ideas and logistic
regression all of this will connect to
how neural networks work
so before I get into you know the mathie
notationing type of material I wanted to
start with some motivation
uh who here has heard of gpt3
yeah a lot of you so it made big waves a
couple years ago is a huge huge model
but it was able to do really impressive
things like in this case here it came up
with a poem on its own right and the
hope is that these deep learning models
learn to be so expressive that they can
do creative things like creative writing
more recently this was very very recent
um
has anyone heard of Dali 2
a few of you yeah so this is very very
recent and so dally 2 is able to
generate images and the prompt here is
an astronaut riding a horse as a pencil
drawing and you can see the the main one
that I picked out and then a bunch of
different versions of what else it can
come up with
so deep learning is very very powerful
for better or worse but it also has so
much potential to do such amazing things
right obviously this is cool but there's
also applications in medicine
applications and education
applications in things like autonomous
driving which could hopefully make our
roads safer
so there's lots of potential here
and that's sort of the backdrop to where
we're going to start we're going to talk
about the origin story of all these
things so we're going to start with
supervised learning learning with
non-linear models so so far most of what
we talked about has been linear models
and now we're getting into the
non-linear territory and I'll talk a
little bit about what that means and
then we'll get started with neural
networks we'll figure out what the heck
they are how we can Define them and that
next lecture we'll actually talk about
how you can optimize them and I believe
Tangy will be giving that lecture
any questions before I get started
cool
all right so first let's think about
linear regression so we've seen this a
bunch and so we can get started with a
data set that we might have right so we
might have some excise and Y eyes
so some inputs and outputs in our data
sets and say our data set is of size n
right
and uh we know for linear regression
that we have a prediction that we can
make according to
something like this
right so we have a linear function that
we're using to predict and this function
depends on our inputs X
can anyone help me out with what our
cost function might look like
in terms of y's and H's
for linear regression
okay H minus y
okay
I heard somewhere
some over I yeah
this looks good to me
this look good to everyone familiar
hopefully we've seen this all before
awesome okay so we have a prediction
here
and we have our label
and what we can do is we can also write
this directly in terms of our parameters
so our parameters here are Theta and B
cool I just plugged it in makes sense so
far right and what we can do is run
things like gradient descent or
stochastic gradient descent in order to
optimize this
cool
so last lecture you talked about a
slightly different set of models you
talked about kernel models
and so with kernel models we still have
a similar setup right so we have our
xi's our y eyes
right and then what is our H Theta of X
look like
so what does our prediction look like
with kernel models does anyone remember
from last class
hint it's very similar to what we had
before
yeah
and what's 5 of x
sorry
the feature map exactly so what's
interesting about this setup is we're
still linear in parameters
right but we're non-linear in the inputs
because Phi of X can be any non-linear
function that you discussed last time
so what if we want to be non-linear in
both the parameters and in the inputs
so generally speaking
what if we want to do something like
this
say our H Theta of X is anything
non-linear so let's say Theta 1 cubed
x 2 plus maybe square root in there
Theta 5
x 4 and maybe square root the whole
thing
right
so this type of model could be a lot
more expressive potentially
right but we also want to think about
how can we make this computationally
tractable how can we make this useful
okay so we have some non-linear model
and by the way all these notes will be
up online afterwards so if you don't
finish writing something please don't
worry about it it will be up and if you
want to follow along I should have
mentioned this earlier but there is a
template up as well
um so it's going to be what I'm writing
on so the blank version
cool
so
let's go back to our
um
our non-linear model now
we can assume
that are excise are in Rd so some Vector
of features
or inputs
and our y i
is some scalar so just an R right this
is pretty standard we've been looking at
this type of formulation a whole bunch
and then our H Theta
is a mapping from r d which is our
inputs to R which is the dimensionality
of our outputs
so the cost function we're going to
think about here for our now non-linear
model
it's going to look very familiar
so for one example
I
we're going to have j i
of theta
is equal to the square of the difference
between the class label and the
prediction so y i minus H Theta
of x i
and all of that squared
so that's the cost for one example if we
want to get the cost for the whole
entire data set we're going to average
so what this is going to look like is
we're going to have JF Theta
1 over n n is the size of our data set
from I equals 1 to n and then here we
have j i of theta
so this is for entire data set
okay so this constant is a little
different from before this is a common
convention in deep learning It's usually
the this is called the mean squared
error so it's usually the average the
constant really doesn't matter your
Optimizer is going to be the same
regardless of what constant you're going
to have out front of that sum does that
make sense
quo
all right so
now we're going to talk about how do we
oh yeah question
why is it there foreign
so n is the size of your data set so
you're just this is the mean squared
error so you're averaging over all the
squared errors in your data set so the
reason the constant doesn't matter is
when you take the gradient your X that's
going to result in your minimum is going
to be the same regardless of whether
it's 1 over n or one over two you asked
why do we use it at all sometimes it's
helpful for scaling but other than that
there's no real
magic behind this it's just a convenient
thing to do makes sense to average over
your errors
um yeah it's a nice way to scale things
thank you no problem
cool so what we want to do once we have
this cost function is we want to
minimize it right
one way to do that we can use gradient
descent and so this notation here we're
assigning
this kind of like coding notation you
can think of we're assigning the right
side
to the left side
okay can anyone tell me why this is
gradient descent what is written here
and not like stochastic gradient descent
what makes it gradient descent
yeah exactly so you're considering the
whole data set here and the reason for
that is if we write out what's actually
going on here our J of theta is so that
1 over n is here and we have I equals 1
2N over j i
uh sorry j i that's Theta
right so we're reasoning over the whole
data set
so each update here considers the entire
data set that we have
cool
all right so here's stochastic gradient
descent
so the idea here is we're considering
now only one single example every time
we update Theta
right so we have some hyper parameter
Alpha
um Alpha same as for gradient descent
some number greater than zero
um and uh we're basically initializing
our parameters Theta randomly at the
start
and then we go through some number of
iterations
we sample uh some example from our data
set and we do this with replacement
and we continue on until either we
converge to something we're happy with
or we reach our and it are maximum
number of iterations
so this is with replacement
um I'm gonna briefly sketch out what SGD
usually looks like more commonly in deep
learning settings just so you guys have
an idea so this is one variant here is
going to be another one
and so the variant that's in algorithm
one that's going to be in your notes
this other one is not but I just think
it's helpful to know some of the
terminology when you go into the foreign
deep learning as well
okay so we go through a for Loop
where
um let's say we're indexing at k
we have
one tip and Epoch so Epoch is
basically a term to mean you've gone
through your entire data set
and so in deep learning you'll often see
or if you read deep learning papers
you'll see oh we trained for blonde
number of epochs that's what that means
that's how many times the optimization
is basically gone through the data set
so for k equals one to an Epoch we can
Shuffle the data
and then for J
from one to n eater here we might not
have enough time or desire to go through
the entire data set so maybe we decide
that we want to go through 500 examples
out of the data set and call that an
epoch that's also fine
so we have 4J equals one to n itter
we're doing the same type of update
and here we have no replacement
in this inner for loop with the J index
because we don't want to look at the
same example twice in the data set
does this make sense
yeah
pretty much pretty much and slightly
different terminology
cool
[Applause]
yeah
so you're basically like having this
number
by any form you mean like n times for
like 40 itself like if the
leadership
like and Banks and this other one the
latter so the question is what does an
Epoch mean and uh basically it's if you
go through the entire data set it's how
many times you go through the entire
data set
any other questions here
cool I'll talk about the last version of
gradient descent for today and this is
mini batch gradient descent
so with mini batch gradient descent the
main difference is you're considering b
or a batch number of gradients at a time
the reason we want to do this is with
things like gpus and parallelism this
actually speeds up computation
so uh we can compute B gradients at the
same time or simultaneously as opposed
to doing them sequentially and that can
be quite a bit faster
so let me write out some of that
so we're Computing B gradients
and they look like maybe grad J
J1 F Theta
all the way
two
grad
JB
of theta
and we do this simultaneously
cool
so one question you might be thinking
about how do you choose B
and very often you choose B empirically
so you test things out you look at your
validation set things like that and
you'll talk about evaluation a bit later
as well
but one way to choose B is choose the
maximum B that your GPU memory can
handle
and that's sort of a good way to speed
up what you're doing
but the trade-off is usually and this
might come up in your homework as well
um usually the lower the B the better
the performance
of the algorithm
and I'm not going to talk too much about
why this is the case this is also active
research but just to give you some idea
of how folks go about choosing these
numbers
any questions about mini batch gradient
descent
yeah I guess this is exactly the same as
small American Pacific so that you're
just doing physical I think a lot of
badge as a whole stool
yes yes precisely
any other questions
yep
[Music]
yeah so with replacement means uh say we
picked example two we can pick example
two again
in the future whereas with out
replacement in the corner case it means
if we picked example two within that J
for Loop we will not pick example two
again until we get to the next epoch
you're just randomly choosing one
example it can happen to be the same
example cannot
does that make sense
in the middle one you randomly pick
examples until you reach and it Earth
whereas in the left one you're more
trying to go through your entire data
set and then do that again
any other questions
on anything gradient descent related
yeah
we actually do not Pierce nowhere with
voice replacement
so with the mini batch no because uh
you're considering say say your batch
size is 10 or 64 or whatever you don't
want multiple examples in that to be the
same
you want all the examples to be
different
between batches
um you can you can yeah
um sometimes you don't sometimes you do
um it's sort of like a design choice but
you can in this case when it's saying
without replacement it means that within
one batch you don't have doubles
no worries
other questions
okay
all right
so next we're actually going to Define
some neural networks so we talked a
little bit about how we optimize these
things but we didn't really get into for
example well how do we Define the neural
network yet or how do we compute the
gradients right like when we talk about
multiple gradients how do we actually
compute these things and we need to be
able to do this in a way that's
computationally efficient
and progress in machine learning really
took off in the last you know 10 20
years because of advancements in
Hardware because we're able to paralyze
on gpus and make these things so much
faster and also algorithmic developments
as well of course
cool so uh we're going to talk about
neural networks today and how we Define
them the back propagation which is how
do we compute these gradients that will
be covered next lecture
okay so this example came up at the very
start I think maybe first lecture or
something like that but the example here
we're looking to predict housing prices
right and we looked at how we can do
this with linear regression with linear
models and say with our linear model
given the size of a house we have some
data where we have some you know size
and prices and we can plot them on this
plot and our model maybe looks something
like this
with something like linear regression
okay what's a problem with this
why might this not work so well
any thoughts
yeah that's a good first one
so prediction might have a non-linear
relationship with the input right and we
only have a linear so maybe that model
doesn't capture the relationship that
well
what's another reason this is not great
yes
exactly the second issue with this is
that prices can't be negative and when
we have a linear model like we do they
can right nothing's preventing them from
being negative can anyone think of like
the simplest thing you can do to fix
this problem
yeah
yes you can fix the intercept to be zero
so what does that mean for negative
numbers
so fixing the intercept to be zero would
be this right
yeah
which also doesn't make sense
so one thing we can do
let me write out these four issues first
but I will show you a solution in just a
second
does anyone know a function that can fix
this for us
so I say that later
okay any other ones
yeah Riley's has anyone heard of Rollies
one person with you okay so we're gonna
talk about railings in just a second
okay so the issues
um that we talked about here are the
prediction might have a non-linear
relationship
with the input
and the second issue is
we can have negative braces
okay
so are what we want are relu
to look like
or what we want this function to look
like is something like this
so basically for all things that are in
the negative side we map to zero
so that's what our value is going to be
and what that looks like in math terms
we have our regular prediction
but we want the maximum between what you
know linear regression would output as a
prediction and zero
and then our parameters here are going
to be W and B
so this is value this is how it's
usually written
and this is the notation that we will
use
so you can say that value is a function
of T here
and then really we can just write our
prediction as this value function
which is WX plus b
and uh does anyone know what relu is
what it's called in deep learning terms
yes
any other so like what category of
functions is it in deep learning yeah
exactly activation function
so our value is an activation function
can anyone tell me is value linear
okay raise hands if you think it's
linear
okay non-linear
yeah yeah it is definitely non-linear
the maximum crates or non-linearity
there
okay
so
this is our non-linearity in deep
learning or often is
it's also sometimes called one neuron
okay so going back to our housing price
prediction setup yeah questions yes
activation functions are by definition
non-linear
we'll talk at the end a little bit about
what happens if they are linear
other questions
cool
all right so let's set up our high
dimensional input
example
right so far we've uh especially in this
plot we've been looking at one input one
output so scalar to scalar so what if we
have more features so high dimensional
input
and this is the case when we have X
B in Rd
and Y B still scalar so we're still
predicting housing prices for example
so our
new terminology
for our prediction
is
value of wtx plus b
okay and so our X is just going to be
stacked features or inputs so we have X1
all the way to XD
and this is in Rd
and then our weights our weight vector
W is going to be in what dimension can
anyone tell me based off of how I've
written it
D that's right
because we're making a DOT product with
x
and then our B is called our bias
and it is going to be scalar
what we want to do in deep learning is
we want to Stack these neurons
so output of activation functions
is going to be the input to the next one
and this is what creates that
expressivity of deep learning models
basically they have a bunch of
non-linearities that are stacked one on
top of the other and this becomes a
super flexible framework that can
represent a lot of different domains
okay so now let's make the housing price
prediction problem a little bit more
concrete
so let's say our X is going to be in R4
and say besides PSI size size or a
square footage
which is X1 we're also going to consider
things like number of bedrooms in the
house
um what's another thing maybe we can
consider the ZIP code that the house is
in
maybe it's close to a Subway or
something right
and the last thing we'll consider is
maybe something like wealth of the
neighborhood
so these are our features or inputs
and uh what we might want to do is
compute some intermediate
variables
so what I mean here is maybe there are
some things that
combine some of these ideas
um
and help us make a prediction for what
the price of the house might be so one
example is maybe the maximum family size
that a particular house can accommodate
so what would the maximum family size
potentially depend on
out of the four inputs that we have
size and number of bedrooms yep I would
agree with that so we can also think of
other variables like maybe how walkable
the neighborhood is
and that might depend on the zip code
for example
and the last one is maybe School quality
in the neighborhood
that this house is in
and this will be our A3 so A1 through A3
are some intermediate variables that we
think might be helpful to make
predictions about housing prices
okay well so how could we maybe write
these out in terms of math notation
well let's use our values that we just
found out about and
do value of some linear combination of
the features that we think might make
sense in this context so maximum family
size maybe we have
um combo like someone said there of the
size which is X1 and then maybe we add
the number of bedrooms which is X2 and
we have some bias term
which is going to be theta 3 here so
Theta 1 Theta 2 theta 3 are all
parameters
and then we can do the same thing for
the rest of these intermediate variables
so we can say Theta 4 so walkability
depends on X3 which is zip code and then
we have another bias term and then
finally A3
so we have value
of theta 6
um so A3 is walkability maybe that
depends on
um or sorry A3 is school quality so that
depends maybe on zip code which is X3
and maybe on wealth of the neighborhood
which is X4 and then we have some bias
here as well okay so these are the
intermediate variables that we think
might be helpful here
okay
and the last thing that we might want to
do here is
is
um
let me sorry let me just change this
notation so it's not confusing for the
notes later these are all W's and the
biases are going to be B's
thank you
these are
b2's a few ones
make sure
oh sorry
okay no I actually had it right the
first time ignore me
so these are these were all Theta
parameters at the end of the day it
doesn't matter I just want to make sure
that it matches your notes so it's not
confusing later
so one two
three
Theta four
Theta 5.
okay
so this is actually one layer that we
defined here
okay and finally once we have these
intermediate variables we're actually
going to make the output we're going to
construct the output right and our
output is our H Theta of X which is
going to be if we follow this
construction we're going to write value
of
and here we're going to make
combinations a linear combination of
these intermediate variables a right so
we're going to have Theta 9 A1 Plus
Theta 10 A2 plus Theta 11 A3 plus Theta
12.
okay
one thing so this is going to be our end
goal or end prediction here
one thing that usually happens in deep
learning
is we actually for the output we don't
use a relu so it's sort of like
convention
nothing is necessarily stopping you from
doing that is just by convention usually
we just have a linear layer at the end
cool so now that we look at this diagram
that's here on the on your right
so we have all the things that I talked
about right we have the size the number
of bedrooms the ZIP code the wealth and
it's going into these intermediate
variables right so this is A1 A2 A3
okay
and the weights that we're considering
that are relating
um sort of taking from the first set of
inputs X to a so for example here we
have Theta 1 here we're going to have
Theta 2 and so on
this makes sense
and this structure that we yeah sorry
questions
uh right now they're all scalar
everything we're talking about right now
is scalar so whenever we have the
subscript it's usually scalar
yep
um
towards the end you're just using those
intermediate videos it's possible that
some of the original variable files
still be useful so is there any way you
can kind of transport them
yeah I mean if you look at a two for
example if you set the
um say this is X3 is positive and you
set Theta four to one and Theta 5 to 0
then you transfer over all the
information from
three pretty cool
okay but this structure we came up with
the structure based off of our knowledge
right this was not something that was
determined by some algorithm we just
came up with it because it seemed to
make sense
so this is called prior knowledge
and infusing your model with it
basically
but
what if we want to be a little more
General
what if we don't want or don't have the
prior knowledge to do this in a way that
results in good performance
so this is getting into something called
fully connected neural network
and what this means is we no longer
think about these ideas of family size
walkability School quality
we don't know what those intermediate
variables might be but maybe they depend
on all of the inputs so each
intermediate variable will depend on
every single input so this is going to
get messy but I'll try to use different
colors
so every single
variable here will depend on all the
ones that came previously
and this is a much more General way of
thinking about this
right we don't have to infuse this prior
knowledge into the system we can let the
neural network figure it out
so what this looks like
mathematically is maybe we would have
like A1
uh b equal value of you know some weight
X1 plus some weight X2 plus some weight
X3 plus another weight X4 and plus the
bias term
and we can do this for A2 and so on and
so forth does that make sense
cool
so what this looks like if we start
looking at Vector notation now more
this might look like this so we have A1
is equal to their value
of of W1
this
higher index
notation in square brackets is going to
refer to layers
so this would be the first layer and
this would be the second layer in this
network
so we have W1 layer one transpose with
all the inputs X now this is a vector
so now we're doing a DOT product
and we add some bias term
okay
can anyone tell me what dimensionality W
uh W1 in the first layer is
yeah yes that's right
and that's because our X is
dimensionality four
and our bias is still a scalar
okay and then we can do the same thing
we can say
this
still first layer
okay
and last one
same thing
okay and then finally we have our
prediction
and the prediction now is going to use
weights from the second layer
and it's going to operate on those
intermediate variables a
okay so we're going to have W2
and here we have B2
and now W2
is going to be of what dimension
yeah I heard it somewhere
yes
because a is of Dimension 3 here
and the bias still scalar
okay so this is a two layer
neural network
and this is the same thing as saying we
have one hidden layer
so intermediate variables are referred
to in deep learning as hidden units and
the associated layers are hidden layers
okay any questions on that
yeah uh yes
great question great question
um so you're going to be limited by
compute but aside from that it's a lot
of experimentation
so for example gpt3 has a lot a lot of
layers but it's also dealing with a lot
of data if you have just a little bit of
data and just a few examples you
probably don't want to use a very big
model
and I think you'll talk a little bit
about why shortly
any other questions yeah
different hidden units if they're all
relying on the same input so the hope is
that the network learns different
representations but technically nothing
is really stopping it from exactly what
you said just replicating ideas but it
often doesn't
um
and it's trying to learn these A's in
the best way that can help the neural
network make a prediction H Theta of X
right so this ends up working actually
quite well
yeah
for example
um
[Music]
yeah so that's actually an active
research area as well it's called
interpretability in deep learning and
either figuring out if there is any
or figuring out how we can induce there
to be some level of prior knowledge so
some interpretability
I think there's a question at the back
yep
yes
that you're going to be applying to what
yes so w are the weights that you're
going to be applying to the x's and then
W so those are W1 with the square
bracket at the top and then W2 with a
square bracket at the top is going to be
the weights you're applying to the A's
yep
all right
okay so this is some notation yes yes
question
is just linear and so what's the point
of the neural network versus just a
writing
um
yeah so that's a great question you're
completely right if you get rid of the
values things are just going to be
linear their values are what make uh the
neural network be more expressive so
those non-linearities those activation
functions are really the heart of the
neural network
okay cool I'm going to move on in the
interest of time so we have a two-layer
neural network
and we just talked about uh all these
things the only difference here is that
we're changing notation a little bit so
we're introducing the Z which is just a
linear combination of x's with our
weights and our biases and then we still
have our A's the number of A's here is M
so this is the number of
um
hidden units that we're considering so
we had three in the last example more
generally we'll have m
um and then yeah that's otherwise this
is exactly what we just wrote out before
this make sense to everyone any
questions on this
okay
so we're going to talk about
vectorization
we're going to make this even more
vectorized right so we had like a lot of
notation a lot of indices here we want
to get rid of as much of that as
possible one to make things cleaner and
not have to write all these indices
everywhere and two which is the more
important reason vectorization actually
makes things faster
it makes things uh better able to be
paralyzed on for example gpus
so what we can do first is think about
those weights in our first layer right
those W's with the square square bracket
one
and what we can do is we can transpose
them so they're rows and stack them in a
matrix
and so what we're looking here at here
is M by D
so m is our hidden unit dimension
and D is our input dimension
so these are all the weights
in our first layer
and then what we can do is we can
actually write out those equations from
before in this vectorized form where for
example we can write out Z1 if we take
the first row of this
Z1 will be W1 of 1 transpose X1 plus B1
1 right which is that first row that we
had before
okay and but this looks way way nicer
and this is our vectorized notation any
questions on this
so it's the exact same thing just more
compactly written
cool
[Applause]
foreign
this is actually called preactivation so
this is before we applied our values
and we have these Z's this is couple
capital W I'll do it with those little
bars at the top
um and
it's all our weights from our first
layer
we take the X and we add our biases
which are also stacked together
and all of this is going to be of
Dimension M which is the same Dimension
as our hidden units
now we want to get A's out of this and
to do so we need to apply the relu to
every element in the Z vector
so our A's are A1 through a m
and we want to apply relu
to each one of these Z's
we're actually going to abuse notation
here a little bit
and we're just going to write this by
definition to be value of Z
so it's an element-wise
operation and we're going to refer to it
the same way as we would for a scalar
okay
and then what we can do is we can write
our second layer weights
in the second layer we only have a
scalar output that we want
so we only have one
weight
Vector to include here that we're going
to transpose to be a row
and this is going to be in dimension 1
by m
any questions on that part
okay
and we're still going to have our bias
in the second layer which is still
scalar and so our final output here
is going to be
this W2 Matrix times a uh dot productive
with a and the bias term
and what I said before is that
vectorization helps us paralyze things
on gpus
okay
so we talked about two-layer neural
networks what if we have more layers
so notation just follows right so before
we stopped with one hidden layer which
is a two layer neural network and now
we're going to have R minus 1
hidden layers which is an R layered
neural network
and like I mentioned before so all the
hidden units will have values whereas
the hidden layers
whereas the prediction just by
convention will not
and we'll refer to these big W's as
weight matrices
and these bias terms will just be called
bias nothing really changed
and these A's will be hidden units
one thing to note is the dimensionality
of these A's right so what is the
dimensionality
of a
k
so a layer k
and that's going to be we're going to
refer to that as MK
okay and so can anyone tell me what the
dimensionality is of w layer one
so I say that louder
D cross k
what do folks think
so it's
K cross d
is that looking yeah
yes
yes there we go okay so it's M1
cross D so D is our input so we want
this uh Matrix to do matrix
multiplication with x x is of Dimension
D so we want that last Dimension to be D
the First Dimension is the dimension we
want as the output the output will be A1
A1 is of Dimension M1
does that make sense
okay
and then so just for
practice what would W2 be
yeah
[Music]
this would be an R layer network with r
minus one hidden units
what is the dimensionality of W2 can
anyone help me
M2 cross M1 because the input will be a
one that's what's being multiplied with
W2 and the output will be A2 so we want
M2 output
okay cool and so this can more generally
we can write this for WK
we're going to have our
um MK cross MK minus 1.
and b k
is just going to be
um MK
dimension
any questions here
no okay awesome
so we got this question earlier
why do we need an activation function
relu can anyone remind me why do we need
it
yeah so it's our non-linearity it's what
makes what we're doing here non-linear
but for fun let's see what happens if we
don't have the relu
at all
or we have it be just identity
this is a one sorry
okay
so we have our hidden layer A1
and then say we only have one hidden
layer so our output here
is going to be W2
of a
plus B2
okay
and then
if we actually substitute in
for A1
what are we going to get so we're going
to have
W2
of
W1
X plus b
okay all of that
a
oh sorry that was a plus B2
right and then we can actually expand it
out
and we're going to get
watch my math so I don't mess this up
I'm gonna get W2 w1x Plus
W2
B1
plus B2
so what does this really look like well
we can Define these to be say this is W
tilde
and say this is B tilde
right the the second term doesn't depend
on X at all
and the first term does
okay so this is just a linear function
of X as we would have in linear
regression
essentially everything would collapse
and we're here linear in these
parameters
any questions about this so if we lose
the value we lose the non-linear
expressivity of the neural network
yep
yeah you can definitely have other ones
um so in the notes I think we mentioned
the sigmoid activation function and the
tan H activation function I would
probably say value is the most common
but it really depends on your
application the kinds of outputs you
might want things like that
um there are definitely other ones and
there's also
b-sides uh just you know the kinds of
outputs that you might want these
activation functions have certain
properties when you
um
try to compute gradients with them and
things like that and that's a little bit
beyond the scope of this lecture but if
you have questions about this later come
come by and I'll be happy to chat
any other questions on this yep
[Music]
perhaps the closest
drink yes why are you still landed so
commonly used despite it being quite
close to me it works well
oh yeah good good good uh Point yes
you're it you're right
thank you I meant it in the sense that
the parameters are going to be linear
here
yep
other questions
okay
okay one last new ish idea I want to
talk about and that is connection
between neural networks and kernel
methods
so kernel methods we talked about this
very briefly at the beginning of this
lecture
so the kernel method output or
prediction is going to look like H Theta
of x
Theta transpose Phi of x
so we're linear
in parameters here
but not an X
yeah everyone agrees
okay so looking at that penultimate
layer AR minus one
what if we write it as Phi B of x
where uh sorry 5 beta where our beta is
going to be all our parameters so our
parameter is W1
um all the way to the penultimate layer
w r minus 1. and also our biases which
are 1 all the way to VR minus one
okay and then we can write the
prediction
from our neural network
as W of R so our last layer
Matrix multiplied with Phi Beta of x
if we fix our parameters
so we're fixing beta here
and we can add our biasterm
okay
so really this looks pretty much the
same
right
the only difference is within the neural
network
Phi Beta is actually learned
so the algorithm is looking for the best
possible features for this data
whereas in the kernel methods we choose
the kernel so there's more of that prior
knowledge and prior structure that we're
infusing into the algorithm whereas here
there's flexibility in that these five
beta parameters can actually be learned
to best fit the data
and because of this sort of structural
similarity
the penultimate layer output a r minus 1
is sometimes called the features or the
representation
within a neural network
and so if you ever hear terms like
representation learning or something
like that it's talking about those
hidden layers within the neural network
and what we're learning there
any questions here
yeah at the back
uh fire e beta
um that's all supposed to be one line
right yes
so the
the
whatever that Greek letter is called is
the only subscript
uh so it's WR
Matrix multiplied with five underscore
beta of X plus all of that plus the
biastern BR
part of the
is not like a subscript at all no okay
thank you yeah so
other questions
no
all right
um so today we talked about two
different things we talked about
supervised learning with non-linear
models
um and what that might look like what
the cost function looks like and the
second thing we talked about are neural
networks how do we construct them we
first started with two layer neural
networks and then expanded that notation
to be our layer neural networks and next
time tangyu is going to talk about back
propagation so how do we actually
optimize how do we perform stochastic
grade in descent or any kind of gradient
descent in this framework so how do we
compute the
gradients for the cost function and for
the neural network
any last questions
okay